the Joe Rogan experience that's
brilliant
yeah like Robert Downey jr. is amazing
as he is it's always gonna be Ironman
like that sometimes you get one of those
roles you know like Thor Chris Helms
women he's [ __ ] Thor
dude you're Thor forever you know you
flirted with that it depends on it and I
think it depends on how many of them you
do but when you did the Hulk were you
worried about that a little bit
was there any hesitation because I was
surprised when you did that this is an
interesting choice as is evident I got
more worried about it
you know I I I was I was very interested
because I loved it I I'm not like snobby
about I loved those like comics and I
just grabbed to him yeah I subscribed to
Hawkeye
all the dark curse that like Dark Knight
Frank Miller trying to hold all of it
was really you know I was it was some it
was it was something I really latched on
to and and I loved the Bill Bixby Hulk
yeah like he's it for me he's always for
anyone in our age like he's you know him
walking away at the end of the show yeah
that's it
and III so yeah no I I I thought I tend
to get just the way I felt about
American History X I actually thought
American History X was sort of like a
fella or Macbeth I thought it was that's
what I said to David he had written is
kind of edgy thing with the drug plot
and I was like I think he strip all that
away and he literally just make this
about rage destroying a person who's got
a lot in him it's like it's like a
Shakespearean tragedy but it's just it's
skinheads
you know and that and that really lit
David up and that's where we went with
that right but Hulk Hulk is like the
it's uh prometheus right the guy who
steals fire from the gods for people but
he gets burned doing it and is cursed
right he's trying to take like the power
of nature back out to people from the
gods and he gets burned and that's how I
that's how I
I was like if we could do something like
that that leans into this guy who thinks
he's going for something good it's gonna
help humanity and he cracks open like
the backside of God and and takes
something out that is not meant to be
taken out and now he's cursed like
cursed you know that that's what was
amazing even as silly as the show was on
some levels Bill Bixby was cursed like
that's what and the end of every show
you were like oh my god it'll cursed
like alone in the world and cursed right
and there's something pretty pretty
heavy in that like pretty cool in that
and uh and so so it was it wasn't um it
you know I thought it was like really
worth of crack I [ __ ] loved it
[Applause]